la pollution des océans par le plastique
est une crise d'envergure planétaire est
une chercheuse québécoise basée en
californie est arrivé à un triste
constat
en plus de provoquer la mort de nombreux
animaux marins le plastique en se
dégradant dans les océans représentent
une source de gaz à effet de serre
jusqu'ici méconnue
[Musique]
chaque année on produit plus de 300
millions de tonnes de plastique dans le
monde
[Musique]
selon une étude récente hatem 9 % de
cette matière seraient recyclés et 12%
est sidéré
l'immense majorité des plastiques 79% se
retrouvent dans les dépotoirs de pire
encore dans l'environnement
[Musique]
et quand on parle de rejet dans
l'environnement ce sont des images comme
celles ci qui nous viennent tant elle
[Musique]
les scientifiques estiment que chaque
année 8 millions de tonnes de plastique
aboutissent dans les océans
il y en a partout du plastique c'est
ouais c'est sur toutes les plages sa
part le monde
trente secondes de marche et puis j'ai
trouvé cet item de plastique bouteilles
de plastique des emballages de plastique
des cons plein
c'était ses trousses
et un énorme problème
problème incroyable au niveau du
plastique
[Musique]
sarah jane royer est aussi à nos graves
depuis quelques années cette
scientifique québécoise alterne ses
recherches entre hawaï et san diego en
californie
sa spécialité les effets de la pollution
des plastiques dans l'océan
aujourd'hui l'homme menace la santé des
océans
mais pour moi en tant que scénographe
les aux siens c'est notre réserve en
thermique c'est la vie c'est ce qui nous
permet d'être au monde aujourd'hui est
donc moi je veux protéger les océans
[Musique]
l'impact du plastique sur la santé des
océans elle est immense chaque minute on
a environ un camion de vidange de
déchets plastiques qui est déversée dans
l'océan
[Musique]
le plastique arrive dans l'océan de
partout et sous plusieurs formes
le vent et la pluie transporte vers les
ruisseaux et les rivières des sacs des
bouteilles des pailles et une multitude
d'autres objets pour la plupart à usage
unique qui finissent souvent par aboutir
dans l'océan
s'ajoutent les micro plastiques
ces particules de moins de 5 mm
contenues dans les savons les
cosmétiques et les produits d'entretien
qui sont rejetés dans les égouts et
c'est sans compter toutes les bouées et
filets de pêche fait de matières
plastiques qui sont perdus ou abandonnés
en mer une fois dans l'océan
le plastique se dispersent
ces déchets peuvent parcourir des
milliers de kilomètres
emportés dans le tourbillon des courants
marins l'hégire océanique
on en retrouve cinq sur la planète sarah
jane royer a pu constater leur impact
sur les côtes hawaïennes
on retrouve une quantité phénoménale de
débris marais les plastiques dans l'agir
océanique peuvent résider pendant
plusieurs années puis vont se fragmenter
ils vont devenir de plus en plus petit
éventuellement quand il ya une tempête
quand les vents sont plus élevés ces
bouts de plastique vont être rejetés de
la jirs et éventuellement vont se
retrouver sur les plages hawaïennes et
les dommages sont durables on estime que
le plastique pour rester dans
l'environnement durant des centaines
d'années était de mise à l'essai
transformé 13 qui se plaît c'est xavier
de plus en plus un petit morceau qui est
accessible
de plus un peu d'animaux marins fait son
petit donc tous des animaux qui se
retrouvent dans l'océan vont à gérer une
plastique par erreur les animaux marins
du plus petit au plus grand confondre
ces morceaux de plastique de différentes
tailles avec la nourriture sont la
commission océanographique de l'unesco
ces débris cause annuellement la mort 2
millions d'oiseaux et c'est sans compter
les 100000 mammifères marins qui perdent
la vie empêtré dans des engins de pêche
fait de plastique
mais la pollution par les plastique dans
les océans risquent de causer d'autres
dommages à la planète jusque là
insoupçonnées parce que le plastique est
produit à partir de combustibles
fossiles comme le pétrole
sarah jane royer s'est demandé si sa
dégradation dans l'océan pouvaient avoir
un effet sur la hausse des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre dans l'atmosphère
pour moi ça ne fait pas une grande
surprise de voir que des gardes un
facteur sont produits à partir du
plastique ma surprise était que personne
ne l'avait étudié sans doute que
l'industrie du pétrole et du plastique
est au courant mais fallait qu'un
scientifique un moment donné faire face
la découverte et puis la pub lycéens
typiquement afin que ce soit connue elle
et son équipe ont fait des tests sur le
polyéthylène la sorte de plastique qu'on
retrouve le plus dans l'océan
ils ont démontré que plus un objet sera
ghm en plus il offre une grande surface
aux rayons du soleil
ainsi il émet davantage de gaz et
deviennent encore plus nocifs pour
l'environnement
commencée que le temps de vie de
plastique est énorme
des centaines d'années ben ce plastique
va va continuer à produire ces gaz à
effet de serre sur une échelle de temps
incroyable je crois que l'industrie du
plastique ne pas tellement aimé la
publication des sites travail et
l'indicé du plastique
lors de mes recherches j'ai demandé de
l'aide j'ai essayé d'ouvrir des portes
discuter avec l'industrie du plastique
puis à chaque fois yeux ayant fermé les
ports paiement dit qu'ils pouvaient pas
avoir de communication avec moi
[Musique]
l'industrie n'a pas de quoi s'inquiéter
depuis le début de la pandémie de kovy
19 la consommation de plastique à usage
unique aurait augmenté de 250 à 300 %
aux états-unis seulement à l'échelle de
la planète des chercheurs ont calculé
que la production de plastique va
doubler d'ici 15 ans et quadruples et
d'ici 2050
plusieurs pensent qu'il est désormais
urgent de revoir notre mode de vie
on est complètement dénuée de
la consommation de plastique
si vous voulez consommer consommer avec
un esprit vers aussi de réfléchir à
votre un pack à votre caisse que vous
laissez derrière vous quand vous
consommez un produit pour protéger notre
ciel nous mêmes
vous amène une partie de notre culture
on de faire attention aux contres
ensemble pour s'assurer que la planète
est en santé
[Musique]